essai
bonsoir le missile tiré hier contre le
palais présidentiel croates étaient
téléguidés il s'agissait donc bien d'une
attaque préméditée destinée à éliminer
non seulement le numéro 1 croate mais
aussi le président de la fédération
yougoslave et le premier ministre du
pays d'origine croate tous les deux
cette information denise de la violence
des combats et de la haine que se vouent
les deux camps le point de non retour
est d'ailleurs atteint la croatie a
proclamé officiellement son indépendance
jean-paul girouard la renaissance croate
touché par un missile
le tableau symbolique est abîmée mais
toujours pendu aux murs du palais
présidentiel de croatie rogne aux tout
jeunes venus constater des dégâts n'a
pas manqué d'accuser l'armée fédérale et
la serbie d'avoir voulu attenter à cette
renaissance et à sa propre vie au moment
où le missile est tombé sur le palais il
se trouvait dans un des bureaux en
compagnie du premier ministre fédéral
andré markowicz et de ce type mais si tu
che le président en titre de l'ex
présidence collégiale yugo stade une
polémique serbo-croate de plus pour les
croates c'est un attentat réalisée grâce
à un missile téléguidé l'état major de
l'armée fédérale dément et accuse les
dirigeants croates d'avoir perfidement
mise en scène cette explosion il a
toutefois accepté le principe d'un
cessez le feu à condition qu'ils soient
garantis par la communauté européenne et
responsable militaire fédéraux et
croates discutent depuis ce matin des
modalités de cette nouvelle trêve au
siège de la mission européenne à zagreb
les débats ont été qualifiés de
constructifs pour l'heure rien d'autre
n'a filtré cette rencontre a tout de
même provoqué une accalmie sensible dans
les combats sur la plupart des fronts le
8 octobre 91 restera de toute façon le
jour j des indépendances croates et
slovènes
le parlement croate qui réunit en un
lieu secret pour procéder à la
proclamation aux postes frontières de
slovénie de longues files se sont
formées pour obtenir les premiers coups
de tampons authentiquement slovène sur
des passeports flambant neuf
l éclatement dû pays embarrasse tout les
yougoslaves attaché à la paix civile et
à l'unité nationale c'est le cas de ce
type et mais dites ce que vous avez vu
dans le reportage de jean paul girouard
le chef de l'état yougoslave est en
effet d'origine croate
mais il aura échoué dans sa tentative de
concilier l'inconciliable
et il ne cache pas son amertume ce type
aimé zych qui a échappé à la main hier
dans le bombardement du palais
présidentiel de zagreb stipe mesic
inquiet pour sa vie et pour son pays est
venu se réfugier aujourd'hui à
strasbourg où il est surtout venu
demander à l'europe d'agir
reportage sur place de laurent andres
c'est alors que les bombes écrasé son
palais que le dernier président de la
république yougoslave a pris sa décision
hier celle de partir après un passage
quasi clandestin en italie ce type et
n'hésitera donc foncer vers la france en
voiture avec sa femme ses enfants et
deux gardes du corps
but du voyage le parlement européen de
strasbourg où il était invité depuis
juillet maison on attendait plus au
coeur d'une europe qui reste malgré les
déceptions des dernières semaines
le dernier espoir de cet homme désormais
traqués ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on a
bien voulu me tuer
ça c'est tout à fait certain parce que
c'était une façon pour eux de résoudre
le problème que je leur pose plus
quelques autres la yougoslavie n'existe
plus aisés salle du de mon voyage dire
aux états unis et à l'europe qui veulent
maintenir cette réalité qu'elle n'existe
pas et qu'il n'y a plus de gouvernement
plus de parlement plus de président de
l'armée a fait un putsch et qu'il faut
que le monde le comprenne et en tire
enfin les conséquences
moi je vous dis que milosevic est plus
dangereux que saddam hussein lui même il
est dangereux pour les autres pays
et cette guerre en croatie est
dangereuse pour l'ensemble de l'europe
et si vous ne voulez pas reconnaître la
croatie nous a dit en conclusion ce type
aimé zych avant de rejoindre le palais
de l'europe reconnaissait donc la serbie
ça reviendra au même l'humour triste
d'un homme au bout de sa route
de nombreux yougoslavie vous le savez
dans notre pays
ils suivent avec une grande inquiétude
l'évolution de la situation dans leur
pays d'origine particulièrement les
croates qui ont choisi leur camp
communautés croate ses quarante mille
personnes en français depuis le début de
la crise il se mobilise pour envoyer une
aide humanité en croatie
une aide qui s'intensifie et vous allez
le voir même certains français
n'hésitent pas à aller se battre aux
côtés des croates reportage de caroline
since he marque doux après un voyage de
plusieurs jours ce camion arrive juste
de zagreb où il a acheminé l'aide
humanitaire envoyée par la communauté
croate de france 0-2 les gens n'ont plus
rien il a d'énormes besoins à zagreb
la situation est un peu meilleure mais
partout en province les gens dorment
dans les caves dans les dépôts ils n'ont
plus rien à manger
toujours rien pour ce glacier cette
église du 20e arrondissement est devenue
le point de ralliement des croates de
france tous les cartons de vêtements
nourriture ou médicaments ils sont
entreposés
chacun donne ce qu'il peut pour venir en
aide à des compatriotes démunis
de nombreux jeunes sont là des femmes
tous bénévoles
on s'organise tout celle entre nous
après le travail
les étudiantes cadets 1 pas du tout les
lycéens
connaissant pas de classe tout le monde
tu es là rémy est un français de 25 ans
il est rentré de cette nuit de zagreb
comme de nombreux jeunes étrangers il
est engagé volontaire auprès de l'armée
croate pour défendre son idée de la
liberté sur besson
fond des choses absolue absolument
épouvantable ils détruisent tout ce qui
le voit et tout ce qui ressemble à la
culture croate vous tous qui est
population croate
c'est leur cible préférée les hôpitaux
évidemment mais aussi tout ce qui
témoigne de la culture croit-il le
détruise parmi tous ces bénévoles les
prêtres de la mission catholique croate
sont très engagés oubliant pour une fois
leur réserve habituelle ce pas une
guerre civile
c'est une guerre vraie guerre de
conquête une guerre impérialiste demain
son camion chargé de colis repartira
pour agrès d' une chaîne humanitaire qui
peut paraître dérisoire mais pour
l'instant seul soutien d'une communauté
à son pays en guerre
l'espoir d'un retour au pays
s'amenuisent pour le père aristide les
militaires haïtiens qui ont pris le
pouvoir
ignore les avertissements de la
communauté internationale et continue de
dicter leur loi par la force
hier après de nouvelles fusillades et
des élections d'intimidation les
putschistes ont en effet désigner un
président intérimaire il s'agit du juge
joseph nerette ils devraient être
investis dans les prochaines heures
morad aït habbouche
blindés légers soldats en armes en route
vers le parlement haïtien au toujours
déjà une centaine de soldats ont pris
position
coups de feu à l'extérieur à l'intérieur
également un nouveau putsch l'armée
oblige cette fois ci les députés à
désigner un président intérimaire coup
d'état constitutionnel les militaires
invoque l'article 149 contraint et forcé
les députés choisissent le juge joseph
nerette magistrat à la cour de cassation
il devrait être investie selon la radio
nationale
dans moins d'une heure dans le même
temps le premier ministre néo préval est
renvoyé des élections seront organisées
avant 90 jours le général raoul cédras
ce nouvel homme fort a nié être mêlés à
l'attaqué
pourtant ce sont bien ces militaires qui
ont obligé les membres de l'oat à fuir
port-au-prince hier l'organisation des
états américains avaient entamé des
négociations pour un retour à la
démocratie en haïti
aujourd'hui l'eau à envisage d'envoyer
une force de paix sur place quand et
comment rien n'est décidé
en france ce pierre bérégovoy l'ancien
hymne à la joie il faut en finir avec la
sinistrose ambiante dit le ministre des
finances 92 sera l'année de la
croissance
les syndicats apprécieront sans aucun
doute cette bonne nouvelle plus
précisément les syndicats de
fonctionnaires qui ont commencé à
discuter avec jean pierre soisson
mais pour le moment les propositions du
ministre de la fonction publique ne
conviennent pas aux syndicats mais jean
pierre soisson pourrait bien avoir un
joker dans son dossier de négociations
agnès molinier a suivi la réunion 18
heures interruptions de séance et
premières informations
jean pierre soisson propose 5,6 pour
cent d'augmentation sur 91 et 92 des
approbations de tous pour les syndicats
il faut aussi régler le contentieux
depuis 88
ça veut dire au total sept et demi pour
cent pour le groupe des cinq fédérations
d'éducation nationale en tête 10 % pour
fo et pour la cgt carrément l'indexation
des salaires sur les prix
on sent vendredi ceux qui ont voulu
d'une véritable politique cela
qui ne peut pas être celle qu'ont suivie
depuis tant d'années est bien content là
l'aide sociale au mécontentement profond
verità politique salariale qui est à
peine en compte les besoins des gens les
besoins du service public pourquoi j'ai
vraiment une fonction publique de
qualité au service des usagers
c'est une mauvaise question politique
qui concédant tout pays jean pierre
soisson a prévenu la marge de
négociation est étroite mais de source
sûre
il pourrait aller jusqu'à 6% échelonnées
jusqu'en février 93 avec une première
échéance de 1,5 pour cent dès cet
automne s'il parvenait à conclure
l'accord sur cette base il aurait gagné
bien sûr une grande victoire sociale
mais surtout politique obtenir de
l'argent de pierre bérégovoy en ce
moment et qu'une chose que bien des
ministres pourraient lui envier
il faut ajouter aux propos optimistes de
pierre bérégovoy et la bonne volonté de
jean pierre soisson la main tendue par
edith cresson ou syndicats le premier
ministre recevra quatre d'entre eux
vendredi à matignon
la raison d'une telle attitude est
compréhensible le gouvernement veut
éviter une grève générale mais cela
n'empêche pas les syndicats d'être
divisés d'un côté fo qui ne parlent que
de l'organisation d'une grève générale
justement et de l'autre les syndicats
réformistes la cfdt l'a fait la cftc et
la cgt
ils veulent se démarquer demandons
qu'une audience à edith cresson qu'ils
ont obtenus claude guaino et victor
arish laborieuse la réalisation de
l'unité syndicale au sommet dans une
france salariés éclaté en six
confédérations
à peine quelques convergences et est
l'ébauché entre les cinq centrale
réformiste que l'édifice se fissure
dès hier mark mandell avaient annoncé
qu'ils ne seraient pas au rendez vous de
ce matin puisque ses partenaires
refusent de parler de la grève générale
j'ai sollicité pratiquement toutes les
autres organisations
celles ci ont l'air de tourner en rond
pourtant sur le diagnostic tous sont
d'accord pour demander au gouvernement
une autre politique une relance
économique qui fasse repartir l'emploi
mais dans l'immédiat pour ne pas mettre
en péril leur fragile unité cfdt fo cftc
cgc ont préféré se mettre d'accord sur
le minimum qu'on ne te de la gratter
économique et de l'emploi elles ont
décidé d'adresser en commun nous demande
de venir et ce n'est que si l'entrevue
avec edith cresson ne les convainc pas
que les quatre syndicats passons à la
vitesse supérieure car pour la grève
générale aujourd'hui il n'y a toujours
que force ouvrière et la cgt
nous faisons tout pour que l'initiative
formulée par force ouvrière prennent
corps et après il y en aura d'autres et
nous serons de toute la grève générale
est donc toujours dans l'air mais à trop
hésiter les syndicats risquent d'être
pris de court par la base qui ne les
attend pas ici et là pour se lancer dans
l'action
le lycée n'est plus une tour d'ivoire
les problèmes de la cité dans les
banlieues surtout s'infiltre de plus en
plus la violence par exemple que les
profs subissent
c'était le cas dans le lycée romain
rolland de goussainville une grève a
lieu aujourd'hui plus de 90 % des
enseignants étaient en grève la plupart
des élèves se sont montrés solidaires
mais il s'agit avant tout d'une action
symbolique tous savent malheureusement
qu'une journée de grève ne changera pas
grand chose à l'intérieur du lycée
reportage sur place de nathalie
darrigrand et georges mines angoy ben la
sortie de la récréation bon moi j'ai vu
deux individus qui étaient dans une
voiture noire et partir de ce moment
j'ai reconnu l'un des deux individus qui
m'avait cassé auparavant une semaine
auparavant ou 40 voitures et c'est là
qu'ils sont mais sur les tombes de
voitures et puis j'ai reçu un coup de
tête sur le visage et puis les des coûts
les agresseurs ont été interpellés deux
jeunes de goussainville qui
n'appartiennent pas au lycée en six mois
c'est la deuxième fois que ce type
d'agression se produit dans
l'établissement en avril dernier le
gardien a été grièvement blessé par
balle quand j'essaie d'arriver en
1er septembre 90 le lycée et est ouvert
à tous les vents il ya finalement tout
individu
nous nous sommes employés pour obtenir
très très vite
la mise en place d'une clôture
finalement nous sommes contraints à
demandent des postes rétablissement des
mesures qui ne nous satisfont pas pas
nettement puisqu'il s'agit finalement
d'assurer
premièrement sécurité que nous ayons les
moyens de travailler une clôture et
bientôt une grille électronique c'est
tout ce que le proviseur et les
professeurs ont obtenu en deux ans ici
1700 élèves sont scolarisés huit
surveillants seulement assure
l'encadrement placé en zone d'éducation
prioritaire l'établissement ne possède
que des salles de cours en préfabriqué
lycée de banlieue les enseignants tire
de nouveau la sonnette d'alarmé
nous voulons pas que les mêmes causes
produisent les mêmes effets je pense
qu'ils les autorités du pays le
gouvernement a compris la leçon de
l'hiver dernier il ne laissera pas
dégénérer la situation
un commissariat tout proche et des
élèves qui font la grille pour les
professeurs de romain rolland l'urgence
de leur situation ne fait aucun doute
saluons tout de même les bonnes
initiatives qui sont prises par les
jeunes pour les jeunes je vous présente
adb l'année du bac c'est le premier
mensuel fait par des lycéens qui
s'adresse aux lycéens bonne chance ces
nouveaux jeunes confrères un comble la
baisse de la consommation des
tranquillisants voulue par le
gouvernement
va-t-elle augmenter l'anxiété de ceux
qui en prennent hier nous vous donnions
les raisons de cette mesure
aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
à la réaction des consommateurs
mais pour avoir des somnifères il vous
faudra aller chez votre médecin une fois
par mois pour des anxiolytiques une fois
par trimestre ces mesures risquent de se
heurter aux laboratoires pharmaceutiques
bien sûr mais surtout aux consommateurs
de calmants il nie midi il n'imagine pas
vivre sans médicaments et ne veulent pas
voir que ces traitements peuvent les
mettre en danger
catherine matausch alain thomas je
pourrais arrêter les vestaires mais vu
mon âge je veux pouvoir dormir dormir
pour oublier
un français sur trois a choisi d'oublier
ses douleurs son mal-être en consommant
ce que l'on appelle communément des
calmants autre record celui de l' indice
de satisfaction ses calmants sont
efficaces tout le monde est content des
médicaments il y en a beaucoup et de
toutes sortes mais aujourd'hui pour
mettre un frein à cette surconsommation
dangereuse n'est légale anxiolytiques
l'état est obligé d'intervenir en
rappelant une règle élémentaire connu
des généralistes limiter la durée de
prescription pour éviter les phénomènes
de dépendance
votre vie est ce que médecin vous ai
déjà averti des dangers de prendre
longtemps à ce ministère non alors
finalement on aboutit à un patient qui
sera au volant d'une voiture dont on
aurait enlevé tous les clignotants du
tableau de bord et qui pourrait comme ça
conduit à l'aveuglette
face à ce qui est devenu un phénomène de
société l'on peut s'interroger sur les
limites d'une telle mesure c'est d'abord
s'attaquer à un marché florissant
le consommateur lui va-t-il accepter de
renoncer ce qui les soulage le
généraliste enfin peut-il ne pas céder à
la pression de son patient qu'il devra
donc revoir plus souvent il est beaucoup
plus simple de recevoir quelqu'un qui ne
dort pas et lui dire via tenait promet
un somnifère que d'essayer de lui
demander finalement pourquoi il ne dort
pas et de prendre le temps de l'écouter
vous dit on ce d'auto détruits bon moi
je suis d'accord je suis pour le faire
ces résultats et ils font des médecins
le minitel en france devient un maxi tel
dans le monde ces performances sont
elles que les américains adoptent la
première ville américaine à se mettre à
l'heure du minitel devrait être
minneapolis mais l'accord annoncé cet
après midi à genève est beaucoup plus
large c'est un partenariat global entre
france télécom et ios ouest
reportage de notre envoyé spécial jean
jacques peyraud
le minitel version américaine s'appelle
community link liens communautaires
il va fonctionner d'ici quelques jours à
minneapolis pour gagner rapidement tout
le territoire couvert par us west
associée à france télécom dans cette
aventure
la compagnie va proposer d'emblée à ses
clients des services qui nous sont
familiers mais dont le public américain
ne disposait pas jusqu'ici sous cette
forme
la banque lui le paiement de factures la
gestion de budget nous prévoyons
d'offrir aussi des services concernant
les spectacles et les loisirs et une
décision de la cour d'appel ne permettra
aussi d'offrir l'annuaire électronique
lancée il ya douze ans le minitel fait
aujourd'hui de la france le leader
mondial en matière de services
télématiques tant par le nombre de
terminaux accordé il y en a près de 6
millions que par le nombre de services
proposés aux environs de 16 mille
c'est de ce savoir faire et à bénéficier
la nouvelle société franco américaine
fondée
aujourd'hui et aussi de nouveautés
techniques comme ça si en avant première
le premier minis tère photographique qui
propose enfin une image de bonnes
résolutions
un outil très intéressant semble-t-il
pour les sociétés de vente par
correspondance et pour leurs clients
procès quand son deuxième jour les jurés
de la cour d'assises du var se sont
intéressés aux accusés aujourd'hui ont
tenté de comprendre comment des
personnalités aussi diverses se sont
acoquinés côte à côte dans le box des
accusés joël pennel et robert boissonnet
une ancienne tenancière de bar et un
ex-avocat de la bonne société
toulonnaise de personnalité qu'on
imagine aux antipodes dans la vie mais
qui se retrouve bien ensemble face à la
justice
compte rendu d'audience halle berry a
menti et christophe airaud bon père bon
époux robert boissonnet incarne le
notable de province par excellence
ancien avocat juriste catholique
il est décrit comme le bon samaritain
désintéressé et soucieux des lois
pourtant aujourd'hui il est dans le boxe
amateur de peinture de toiles de maîtres
il était l'avocat de suzanne de canson
la riche héritière et de joël pennel
l'aventurière l'accusation lui reproche
d'avoir livré la vieille dame à joël
pennel d'avoir endormi sa méfiance et
favoriser ainsi la captation d'héritage
c'est faux proteste-t-il tout ce que
j'ai fait je les fais pour madame deux
camps sont dans son intérêt pour lui
rendre service
le contraste en tous cas est saisissant
entre ce bourgeois plutôt introverti et
joël pennel fille de marin ancienne
tenancière de bar
franchement expansive elle parle parle
beaucoup et surtout de peinture je peins
dit-elle depuis l'âge de 14 ans on ne
peut pas me donner de style certes
peut-être la peinture provençal juste
une émotion l'a trahi
lorsqu'elle évoque le souvenir d'un de
ses enfants décédés
pour le psychiatre joël pennel est une
mythomane pas au sens pathologique du
terme est une mythomane qui inventent
pour donner l'image de la réussite et
c'est peut-être là la clé de toute cette
affaire une nouvelle à l'instant la
fnsea et le cnj
les deux principaux syndicats des
principaux pardon syndicat des
agriculteurs appellent leurs militants a
renforcé leur pression sur les
représentants de l'état
didier aurillac résume les autres
événements du jour attentat non
revendiqué la nuit dernière à ciboure
dans les pyrénées atlantiques où une
violente explosion a partiellement
détruit une agence immobilière
aucune personne n'a été blessée ces
derniers mois plusieurs agences de la
côte basque ont été victimes d'attentats
des actions signé à chaque fois par
l'organisation séparatiste iparretarrak
obsèques ce matin à rouen et au policier
tué la semaine dernière par un chauffard
en état d'ivresse à titre posthume les
deux hommes ont été élevés au grade
d'officier de paix par le ministre de
l'intérieur philippe marchand le
chauffard un industriel a été écroué il
est accusé d'homicide involontaire avec
circonstances aggravantes
le pdg du lit métal normandie a été
libéré retenu par des sidérurgistes
depuis lundi matin jean louis pierquin a
été finalement relâchée par cette action
les sidérurgistes voulaient protester
contre les menaces de disparition qui
pèse sur le site de mondeville près de
caen
un site qui emploie 13 cents salariés
les manifestants ont obtenu la tenue
d'une prochaine réunion au ministère de
l'industrie
sean penn s'était fait connaître grâce à
son idylle tumultueuse avec madonna il
n'est plus avec madonna mais tient tout
de même à exister c'est possible et
indian runner c'est le titre de son
premier film on l'imaginé états unis la
critique affûté ses armes contre sun
penn le réalisateur
en fait les critiques se sont
transformés en loges le film est bon et
l'examen de passage réussi
thierry stampfler comme un chien enragé
c'est le titre de l'un de ses films et
un peu aussi l'image que sean penn aime
à donner de lui même c'est dire si l'on
guettait ses premiers pas de réalisateur
indian runner raconte l'affrontement de
deux frères l'un est policier l'autre
plutôt voyous la distribution est
intéressante de charles bronson à
valeria golino en passant par patricia
arquette la soeur de rosanna le tout
sous le regard bienveillant de dennis
hooper qui fut longtemps lui un
véritable rebelles dans un milieu du
cinéma ou les révoltés ne font
généralement pas de vieux os
s'il n'échappe pas toujours à une
certaine théâtralité indian runner est
un film dont il émane beaucoup de
vitalité et de sincérité de voter en
masse
une information en y engageant pour
terminer on vient de l'apprendre les
douaniers français ont saisi à 60 kg
d'héroïne à la frontière près de
mulhouse
cette prise record est estimé à 7
millions de francs une ressortissante
roumaine âgée de 36 ans était interpellé
elles venaient apparemment d'allemagne
enfin 17 19 20 marques hautement vous
donnera d'autres informations 22h10 et
michel touré ou parlera du temps bonsoir
adema 19 romans soir